depuis plusieurs heures ils attendent
voisins amis simples particuliers peu de
mots juste une présence symbole
d'affection demain après demain
toutes les grosses d'huile mais pas nous
pas de jungle pas loin du village
alors on lui a dit au revoir aujourd'hui
le convoi passe en silence
seuls les proches sont admis autour de
la maison du préfet les gendarmes ont
établi un périmètre interdit
conformément aux souhaits de la famille
claude erignac reposera ici mardi ses
cendres seront disposés dans une urne au
côté de celle de sa mère un office
d'espérance et d'appels à la paix sera
célébré par le pasteur l'ep les
chrétiens de corse devait se mobiliser
pour faire vivre ces valeurs alors que
tant de messages et de mort veulent
mettre en péril notre société le village
de montbrun est en état de choc il y a
cinq jours ici même le préfet était venu
en visite privée il a voulu voir son ami
monsieur prêter veille chez qui il a
partagé le repas mardi dernier il serait
resté cinq ou six jours de plus
peut-être que l'attentât n'aurait pas
soulevé les 60 habitants suivront demain
avec intérêt la cérémonie d'ajaccio
attentifs aux propos des officiels sur
la corde bien sûr mais surtout à
l'hommage rendu à l'enfant du pays